Karl Lauterbach hat gekifft ja ein
Minister der offen darüber spricht wie
er Cannabis ausprobiert hat Haschisch
ausgerechnet der Gesundheitsminister so
ein gesundmensch ist keine Salze keine
Fette bei ihm in seinem Leben aber schon
mal Cannabis darüber hat er jetzt im
Spiegel gesprochen und dort hat er das
gesagt also die Frage war einfach haben
Sie schon mal Joint geraucht und dann
sagt er ganz klar und ehrlich und offen
ja das habe ich und er spricht weiter
wie das war kommt dann die Nachfrage wie
war die Wirkung wie haben sie das
gefunden angenehm und er sagt und das
ist interessant sehr angenehm Karl
Lauterbach der sagt Cannabiskonsum ich
habe es einmal ausprobiert das war sehr
angenehm genauso wie es sein soll sagt
er entspannt keine Nebenwirkungen und
dann sagt er eben ich habe das danach
aber trotzdem nie wieder gemacht also
Fanta super und woher kam das er ist
groß geworden auf dem Land und auf dem
Dorf und der sagt ganz offen den Wunsch
nach Kontrollverlust den habe ich häuf
gespürt einfach mal loslassen auch das
wollte er ja das ist interessant wie
gesagt übers Dorf spricht er eine
Patricia also er sagt da war eine totale
öde bei mir zu Hause es gab Langeweile
und da haben dann viele sich in die
Drogen geflüchtet eher nicht aber viele
seiner Freunde und später kam der
Ehrgeiz dazu in seinem Leben auf der
Universität er sagte war ehrgeizig er
ist dann nicht den Drogen an einem
gefallen aber es ist tief ins Private
reingegangen meine Beziehungen sind
darüber alle zerbrochen weil ich keine
Zeit hatte also das ist ein ganz offenes
ganz ehrliches Interview bei den
Kollegen vom Spiegel dort von Karl
Lauterbach der erstaunliche Beichte des
Gesundheitsministers einmal ja ich habe
gekifft und dann eben auch warum wegen
der Öde dort auf dem Land das treibt die
dort in jungen Jahren in den
Drogenkonsum hochspannendes Gespräch und
eine hoch spannende beiche des
Gesundheitsministers ja wer hätte das
gedacht er hat also schon einmal gekifft
vielleicht auch so wie wir ihn da hinten
sehen nur ein bisschen in jüngeren
Jahren nicht ganz so sah vielleicht aus
aber der Gesundheitsminister der fand
das sehr angenehm diese und auch der
Kanzler hat ja gerade erst übers kiffen
gesprochen er hat bei einer
Veranstaltung in Magdeburg gesagt er
habe noch nicht gekifft jetzt natürlich
aufs Neue die Diskussion was ist mit
Spitzenpolitikern die das beichten die
sagen ja ich habe gekifft ist das
einfach nur offen und ehrlich ist das
völlig normal viele sagen nee das ist
irgendwie nicht angemessen auch der
Gesundheitsminister dass der sagt ich
habe das ausprobiert und ich fand es das
war ja sein Zitat gerade von Karl
Lauterbach ich fand es angenehm das war
sehr entspannt das wird die Debatte um
die Cannabis Legalisierung hier in
Deutschland noch mal aufs Neue befeuern
[Musik]